a lot of this debate has focused on how
on the issues Kevin McCarthy is
relatively pretty good you know we come
from a world of John Boehner's so I
guess Kevin McCarthy is more
conservative than John Boehner but what
you're saying is no it's really about
trust when we're talking about
leadership elections we need to be able
to trust the leader what you're saying
is you don't think that leader McCarthy
has proven himself trustworthy correct
and that's why we wanted the tools to
where maybe we don't need to trust him
because the individual member is
empowered enough to get the job done and
is not ruled by a dictator as Speaker
this is not a kingdom that we live in we
don't anoint a king I believe that this
is how our founding fathers intended
this process to work our vote is there
to be debated not just rubber stamped
and cast to the biggest fundraiser but
you cannot have good faith negotiations
where trust is absent and so that's why
motion to vacate was so important to me
because that is the check and balance if
you break trust if you don't do what you
promised well buddy you're out of there